Tony how's it going bro good I've just
been in your house of literally I've
just met all your tenants
I really have I've met Alex I'm shook
his hand and he showed me around the I
tell you what make the condition is
really good the kitchen in the dining
room is massive I was shocked at the
size of it of them I've looked into the
area and stuff I've spoken to a few
agents really it's just the top room
isn't it that needs to get it's the top
room that's sticking you've got four
noise tenants in there they seemed
really nice they're all paying three to
five a month I think that top room if
that was renting out I think you
presumably beat you be you be getting
some nice cash flow that I already mad
John but if you if you've all yeah but
then that would be then six bedrooms
right oh I personally I probably
wouldn't be spending loads of money
converting it and I would be just
thinking let's get that top room lent
you that rent it out if you're then
getting sort of like around about
sixteen seventeen hundred pound a month
rent you know that's not bad
considering you bought the house for 104
so I've spoken to a company call and
there's a lady called who's the director
of the company and she said that this
the she thinks this is a part of that
there are parts of Doncaster that are
oversaturated there's a lot of HMOs in
Doncaster but this particular part of
Doncaster with it being just two hundred
meter
from the train station and stuff she's
very confident she could rent that top
room out if you wanted to have a chat
with her I mean it might be that the
agent you've already got you're already
using could rent it out I'm not saying
they're bad but it is quite happy with
the area she knows the area like the
back of her hand
[Music]
yeah right sure
yeah so they just so you think there's a
company that I just buying absolutely
loads of massive buildings and renting
them out and you think it might because
that's never thing I'm thinking I mean
but if you bought the house for 104 did
you buy did it come with a lot of the
furniture and stuff and good come in
decent condition like it is now with the
furniture in that or have you out spend
that don't ever do a refurb on it okay
okay so I mean what are these what what
you - its he provided were you with Tony
might be worth yeah
[Music]
so now you with them though now you've
gone with them and you went with them
because they were the fastest T's oh I
think you could possibly look I mean I
used Utility Warehouse and they have all
the bills and everything is all on one
bill they're not necessarily always the
cheapest but I imagine they're gonna be
a lot cheaper than British gas that
could be another thing another way of
getting extra money in your pocket get
the fifth room let get change the to
look at check-ins look at switching the
utilities I mean I know you got loads of
times you get into it you're a busy guy
you know lot myself but but these little
things that could make a big difference
[Music]
but you've got a license you got a
license well if it's fully licensed and
the councillor happy I think rather than
planning on changing it around and
getting on Suites put in there and all
that you've got four happy tenants in
there paying three to five you've got
one empty room you've got high utility
bills if we just get that top room let
try and see if we can save some some
money on the utilities and stuff just
get a quote it's nothing to do any harm
you know that that that would be my
probably my best advice on on the
property I think I think that's what
obvious say but if there's anything you
want meat you know there's anything I
can do to help I mean I'm very happy to
because you know do you all want this to
be a profitable house for you because
you you've bought it on my
recommendation so
I mean what what do you want me to do no
no don't what would you get a six room
if you're already struggling to get let
the fifth room out
you don't want extra or I would just
rent the floor yeah it's gonna cost you
more money get a flute all I wouldn't
make think it's gonna need more hassle I
think it's gonna be more money I
wouldn't do that personally the guys
that are in there now
the previous tones fine but the guys are
in there now just met all four of them
and and and and and I think there's a
couple of girls and a couple of guys and
and they're really really nice really
polite clean the house is tidy the house
looks great but the fingers no the thing
is though if they if they're letting
people sleep over maybe if they're
bringing their girlfriends in but you've
got a contract just with the one person
you can't supervise you can't know
exactly who's in there
yeah sure yeah that's gonna happen
because when they go in lolly just went
in I just they'll be really impressed
I'll be really pleased there's a lot of
horrible properties around on Cass
they're really nasty HMOs they'll go in
yours and they'll be like oh this is
nice just just don't go just just stay
away yeah yeah oh I wouldn't even go
yeah yeah yeah yeah you might I think
you've got a good house I think you've
got a good house is we need to get that
top room lat I agree
I think oh I think I agree I think I
grew I think the big problem is we need
to get that top room left because that's
going to be extra cash you know that's
yeah that's going to it's going to
suddenly go it's gonna slowly be a lot
more profitable with that fifth room
that so so let me know but call me on
the agents or all that I think you're
getting too involved if you just say to
the agent look agent I want my I want
the house and good stayed in good
condition I want my rent on time and
it's a license for five people it's five
bedrooms for five people so just make
sure that when you move people in it's
one person per bedroom if they have
their extra brother in let them let them
keep it secret from you but as long as
they're not on the contracts just if the
agent should be saying to them look you
can come over two nights a week but you
know we don't the landlord
because of the license you can't have
them in you can't live there and then
what they'll do is if they go okay then
they'll just be staying two nights a
week but then they keep it secret then
as as long as they're not on the
contract but are those six no but are
those six people actually on all on the
contract or if they're just four people
on the contract and they just letting
someone live there where there's only
four people on the contract and then
there's an extra two of the people
living there how can you know all I've
got I've got dozens and dozens of
properties all I know is I know what
who's on the contract and I don't know
who's paying me rent so honestly mate no
no no I don't believe just try and get
just trying just they're not going to
pay they're not going to you can't you
can't say to them all there's to be
living there you need to go move up to
the room and pay me extra rent it's not
going to happen we just need to find
another tenant it's not going to happen
because they're living now on the on the
low it kind of in the secret I wouldn't
worry about it I just get that top room
rented out and did you want me to
message you his detail so you can have a
chat with her because she is literally
like just she's just messaged me and
said yes this area would work very well
what's the London's details Oh am I and
listen if there's any yeah yeah yeah
well I also think as well on another
note Doncaster I'm buying a property
I've literally just been transferring
stuff over to my solicitor and that all
I'm buying in Doncaster at the moment I
think that from a capital appreciation
point of view
Doncaster is gonna do really well as
well so overall my I am happy but I just
think there's a few teething problems
there's a room stick in but hopefully
and or or your current company will be
able to get that fifth room there in the
next and that's a couple of weeks
nothing that's gonna make a big
difference along with the utility bills
maybe shrinking
that's all right my listeners I've been
helpful that's all right mate I'm glad
to help and yeah I hope it works out
keep me posted a get on your welcome mat
keep in touch bye bye